former NBC News anchor Matt Lauer is
breaking his silence amid new
allegations of rape almost two years
after being fired from the network in an
open letter yesterday Lauer denied he
sexually assaulted a co-worker while
working at the 2014 Winter Olympics in
Sochi Lauer said his relationship with
Brooke nevels was completely consensual
and called her rape allegation
categorically false the graphic details
are revealed and groanin Pharos soon to
be released book catch and kill in a
fiery response to the rape allegation
against him former Today Show host Matt
Lauer in a public letter stated his
silence has been a mistake
writing for two years the woman with
whom I had extramarital relationships
have abandoned shared responsibility and
instead shielded themselves from blame
behind false allegations Lauer directed
most of his sharp denials of the sexual
misconduct allegations against him
toward Brooke nevels who told Ronan
Farrow in his new book catch and kill
that the former NBC anchor raped her in
his hotel room during the Sochi Olympics
in 2014
Lauer writes there was absolutely
nothing aggressive about that encounter
she was a fully enthusiastic and willing
partner at no time did she behave in a
way that made it appear she was
incapable of consent in a statement to
NBC News on Wednesday nevels called
Lauer's open letter and attempt to bully
a former colleague into silence she says
I am Not Afraid of him now regardless of
his threats and the shaming and
predatory tactics in catch and kill
Ferrell also writes he uncovered seven
allegations of workplace sexual
misconduct against Lauer predating his
November 2017 firing in a memo to
employees NBC News chairman Andy lack
says any suggestion executives knew of
allegations against Lauer before his
firing are absolutely false and
offensive in a statement NBC called
Lauer's conduct appalling horrific and
reprehensible adding he was fired within
24 hours of us first learning of the
complaint from nevile's Farrell also
reveals new accusations involving
disgraced Holly
Mogul Harvey Weinstein Farrow claims
Weinstein used Lauer as leverage to
suppress stories about himself and made
it known to the network that he was
aware of Lauer's behavior and capable of
revealing it Farrow eventually took the
Weinstein story to The New Yorker and
his memo lack defended the network's
handling of the Weinstein story saying
Farrow simply didn't have a story that
met our standard for broadcast Stephen
Batali oh is a media reporter for the
Los Angeles Times the NBC News bosses
tend to be very supportive of their
executives unless there is flagrant
wrongdoing I doubt that we're going to
see any type of executive changes
because of this on Twitter Wednesday
nevels broke her silence and said she
wanted to thank the many survivors who
shared their stories with her and
offered their support Ronan Farrow this
book catch and kill goes on sale October
15th he will join us in studio 57 here
Monday